an exclusive interview attorney General
William bar says special counsel Robert
mother could have said whether he
believes President Trump committed a
crime chief legal correspondent Jen
Crawford traveled with var to Alaska
where he's listening to the unique
concerns of Alaska Natives their
interview lasted nearly an hour and jen
was able to press the Attorney General
on issues ranging from obstruction of
the Russia investigation to his review
of how that investigation began back in
2016 Jen Crawford is with us from
Anchorage Jan what did the Attorney
General have to say well I mean right
out the box he said he was surprised
when the special counsel told him that
he was not going to be making a decision
on whether or not the president
committed the crime of obstruction of
justice he said he didn't really press
him on that but then he and his lawyers
at the Department of Justice analyzed
the evidence muddler had gathered and
made the decision himself he said that
he couldn't exonerate the president you
looked at that evidence and you did I
mean what's the fundamental difference
between your view and his well I think
Bob said that he was not going to engage
in the analysis he was he was not going
to make a determination one way or the
other we analyzed the law and the facts
and a group of us spent a lot of time
doing that and determined that both as a
matter of law many of the instances
would not amount to obstruction as a
matter of law as a matter of law in
other words we didn't agree with the
legal analysis a lot of the legal
analysis and the report it did not
reflect the views of the department it
was the views of a particularly or
lawyers and so we applied what we
thought was the right law that decision
offered up in a four page summary open
the Attorney General to criticism the
response was that you were too soft on
the president that actually the special
counsel is a little sharper on
instruction I was trying to state the
bottom line and the bottom line was that
my mother identified some episodes he
did not reach a conclusion he provided
both sides of the issue and he his
conclusion was he wasn't exonerating the
president but he wasn't finding a crime
either I do not believe it is
appropriate for me to speak further
about the investigation
well bar testify before Congress about
the special counsels report Muller wants
the report to speak for itself
and signaled he does not want to testify
do you think he should it's up to Bob
but I think the line he's drawing which
is that he's going to stick to what he
said in the report is in the proper line
for any Department official we asked
Barr about Muller's final caution that
there were multiple systemic efforts to
interfere in our election how's the
Justice Department working now to ensure
this doesn't happen again in 2020 yes
well you know we we do have a I think a
increasingly robust program that is
focusing on foreign influence in our
election process
I talked recently to be the director of
the FBI about putting together a special
high-level group to to make sure we're
totally prepared for the upcoming
elections do you think enough what's
done in 2016
probably not the president has
repeatedly accused former intelligence
officials of dropping the ball by
fixating too much on his campaign you've
testified that you believe spying
occurred yes into the Trump campaign yes
you've gotten some criticism for using
that word yeah I mean I guess it's
become a dirty word somehow it hasn't
never been for me I think there's
nothing wrong with spying the question
is always whether it's authorized by law
some former intelligence chief said the
president has made that word somewhat
pejorative that there's fine and it's
there's a witch-hunt this is a hoax and
so you're used to that word makes it
seem that you're being a loyalist you
know it's part of the craziness of the
modern day that if a president uses a
word then all of a sudden it becomes off
bounds it's a perfectly good English
word
and you use it what have you seen what
evidence what makes you think I need to
take a look at this like many other
people who are familiar with
intelligence activities I had a lot of
questions about what was going on I
assumed I think I get answers when I
went in and I have not gotten answers
that are all satisfactory and and in
fact have probably more questions and
that some of the facts that that I've
learned
don't hang together with the official
explanations of what happened what do
you mean by that
that's that's all I really will say
things are just not jiving now Barr said
that he believes that government
interference into the u.s. election is
just as dangerous as foreign
interference and that's why he's started
this new review of the intelligence
community's actions leading up to the
2016 election and he said he asked the
President to that give him the authority
to declassify certain information that
he believes would be in the public
interest Tony so Jen now that the
Attorney General has that authority did
he indicate whether he'd be willing to
work with the intelligence agencies
before deciding what to Declassified he
did not only was he willing but he
already has he's already spoken with
them he said they're being very
supportive of those efforts and he said
you know that he does have the authority
to make those decisions on his own and
there may be the exceptional
circumstances he put it where that would
be necessary but he intends to cooperate
if he intends to work with them and they
are being cooperative and he said he
found it amusing to read media reports
and complaining and fears about him
leaking classified information he's been
in this business 50 years he said he
started at the CIA and he knows how to
protect classified information and he
said he is going to do it alright Jen
thank you very much we'll have more of
Jan's exclusive interview in our next
hour Barr talks about his relationship
with the President and if he regrets
taking the job as Attorney General